C'est une photo de la cathédrale du
Puy-en-Velay. Pourquoi j'ai choisi cette
photo ? Parce que l'Europe, ce ne sont pas d'abord des directives, ce n'est pas d'abord
une organisation administrative... Pour
nous, l'Europe, c'est d'abord une culture,
c'est une civilisation, c'est une
identité. Et à force de l'oublier, on a
laissé le communautarisme changer notre mode de vie. Par rapport à ce défi, il y a
ce soir plusieurs attitudes : il y a ceux qui veulent déconstruire
l'Europe, il y a ceux à l'inverse qui
s'accommodent que l'Europe devienne
multiculturelle et que petit à petit
elle perde son identité. Avec
François-Xavier Bellamy, nous sommes la seule liste à croire dans l'Europe mais une
Europe des racines qui défend ses
frontières, qui assume la réaffirmation
de son identité et qui, surtout, retrouve
l'envie de transmettre à nos enfants la
fierté de ce que nous sommes. C'est ça
l'Europe pour laquelle on se bat.
M. Bayrou, avec M. Macron, c'est juste une protection européenne. Mme
Le Pen, c'est juste une protection nationale. Nous, ce qu'on pense, c'est qu'au contraire, il
faut articuler, nous sommes les seuls à faire cette proposition, une double protection
de nos frontières. Une protection européenne d'abord parce
que c'est une évidence qu'il faut que
l'Europe nous aide à protéger la
frontière grecque, la frontière italienne, la frontière espagnole,
parce que les gens qui passent par là
ensuite arrivent nécessairement chez nous.
Et c'est d'ailleurs l'une des choses que
je ne comprends pas :  Mme Le Pen, vous
vous êtes systématiquement opposée à la construction d'une défense européenne de
nos frontières. C'est l'un de nos points de désaccord. La
deuxième chose, c'est que nous pensons
par contre qu'il faut aussi que la
France ait la maîtrise sur la question
de l'immigration illégale, de ceux qui
rentrent ou qui ne rentrent pas à
l'intérieur de son territoire.
Ce qu'a expliqué M. Macron, c'est qu'il fallait répartir
les migrants entre les pays européens, précisément votre question. Ce qu'il a
dit, c'est qu'il fallait créer des
centres de demandes d'asile
supplémentaires sur le sol européen. Nous, ce qu'on croit c'est qu'il faut
faire l'inverse : les demandes d'asile
doivent être faites de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée. Aujourd'hui, ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on donne une prime à l'entrée
irrégulière sur le sol européen et nous
pensons que c'est une folie.
L'incarnation, c'est quand même ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui en France depuis deux
ans. Notre pays a le record de délivrance
de titres de séjour et ça c'est
depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron.
On va expliquer à celui qui prend sa voiture et
qui fait 10 km pour aller travailler que
c'est lui le pollueur ? Nous, ce qu'on veut
en matière de développement durable, c'est qu'on se fixe des priorités. Les
priorités, ce sont d'abord de retrouver la
maîtrise par rapport aux importations de
pays qui ne respectent pas nos règles.
La taxe carbone que le gouvernement a
décidée de mettre en application en 2018
sur tous ceux qui vont travailler avec
leur voiture, tous ceux qui prennent leur
voiture, elle est toujours en oeuvre,
toujours. On a pénalisé le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et à l'inverse, on
n'a rien fait pour les produits importés... À l'arrivée, c'est le même air, c'est la
même eau, c'est la même planète et donc
nous ce qu'on veut c'est retrouver le
bon sens et commencer par pénaliser ce
qui est fabriqué dans des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos règles.
Au bout de deux ans, jamais
l'Europe n'a été aussi fragmentée et vous avez été l'acteur de
cette dislocation donc vous ne pouvez pas ensuite venir ici
en disant : on va être le rempart de
l'Europe.
La réalité, c'est que l'Europe n'a jamais
été aussi faible et la France jamais
aussi isolée à cause des rodomontades et des leçons qui ont été administrées par
Emmanuel Macron.
Jamais dans notre
histoire,
on a été à ce point là aussi gravement
abîmés avec le pire déficit budgétaire
de la zone euro et donc moi je suis
contre le fait de faire des promesses
qu'on est incapables de tenir parce que
promettre qu'on va baisser les impôts
alors qu'on n'a pas fait d'économies sur
la dépense publique, comme le
gouvernement était incapable de le faire,  ce n'est pas réaliste.
Dans cette
élection, cette fois-ci, vous avez le
choix.
Dans cette élection, il faut voter par
rapport à vos convictions.
C'est le moment de vous exprimer. C'est
le moment de vous faire réentendre et je
m'adresse à tous les Français : la liste
que nous portons avec François-Xavier
Bellamy, cette liste d'union de la droite
et du centre, c'est la seule qui porte un
projet européen autour de convictions
claires : la fin de l' élargissement, la
volonté de retrouver une Europe des
projets, une Europe qui défende ses
frontières, qui retrouve l'audace
économique, qui puisse lutter contre le
gaspillage de l'argent public et
l'Europe aussi qui réaffirme ses racines
chrétiennes, son identité face à
l'islamisme.
Notre liste est la seule qui pourra
faire entendre cette voix au Parlement
européen et c'est la seule alternative
entre un pouvoir qui a failli et le
chaos des extrêmes.